how's everyone doing today
okay so i see a few of you are here but
um
all right great great to see you durba
how's everyone else
okay uh asish um yes if you cannot
uh join the live session you can watch
the recorded session
i will show you today how to do that dr
cheney hello all right hello everyone
and it is three so let's get started we
have a lot to cover today so hopefully
this is going to be a useful session
today
we're going to do a few things i'll
start slow
we'll get to a practical hands-on
session
before we begin i want to show you
where you can always find the
information that you need
if you are not present here in person so
remember that all of the program
information
is going to be found on the program page
you can search here for the program page
lbrn or mxlogic data science
and if you are a member so let me just
copy this over here
you should be able to see not only what
i see
in the beginning but also you can see
that the first session
is already posted right here so asish
yes this is where you can find all the
previous recordings and of course
today's session link is also given right
here
so hopefully that answers that question
are there any other questions before we
begin
all right so there are no other
questions let's start with
the session today so first of all
the onyx logic data science program is
designed to give you an overview
of different types of omics data which
is what we will do today
and in general it is separated into two
different parts the first part is to
kind of get you started
with the data knowing how to handle data
knowing how to explore data visualize
data so that's what we're going to be
starting off
and then in the second part is going to
be about machine learning statistical
analysis
and discussion of how these methods
could be used in a variety of different
projects
so today's session the goal is to really
discuss again the going too fast
so today the goal is to really
look at some of the data types and the
project
examples that we're going to be using in
the session and
uh one of the things that we started
talking about last time
is that it is very useful to get
started for those of you that don't have
a lot of biology background
by going through the bytes and molecules
course if you're more coming from a
engineering perhaps uh background that
would be the place to start
in the introduction to bioinformatics
course there's a survey
which you can fill out to let us know
about you and we will be
uh looking forward to connecting with
you and learning more about your
goals and objectives and so hopefully
you can fill out that survey
and then the material for this course
conceptually that you can start going
through
is found in this course seven biomed
machine learning for biomedical data
so maybe i could pause here a second and
ask how many of you
actually had the chance to go through
any of these courses
and try to complete some of them
and maybe if you have if you have done
at least one
put number one if you've done more than
one then maybe put two
if you've done nothing then put zero
that's also okay
all right excellent all right thank you
all right so for those of you that have
not started yet
i recommend trying to do that maybe over
the weekend
all right thank you ethan hidaya kisembo
okay so if you haven't really started
please try to get started with those
courses they will supplement a lot of
the things that we do here in these
sessions
and we'll give you a sense of where
we're going now the other part that i
wanted to mention
is that we will rely on the onyx on the
tbi
info platform to process some of the
bigger data sets
has anyone and we typically see that a
lot of people
have trouble logging in or they don't
really understand
what information to use for that did
anyone have trouble logging into the tv
info platform and if yes
is it that you can't get in or once you
got in you didn't know what to do
so maybe you could also share that just
to make sure before we go on we will try
looking at some of these methods today
to kind of talk about how
they are useful and what we're going to
be doing
did anyone have any trouble or did
anyone try
okay so rebecca maybe you could try that
now
this is the link
okay you can try logging in with the
same credentials that you have on the
learn omixlogic
portal this platform allows you to
process
large data sets each one of you has an
educational account which means that i
will be going through some examples
and showing you how the data goes from
raw
to structured in today's session and
also next session
so please try and let us know
if you have any issues
finally there are some exercises
that allow you to play around with
coding
on the portal and we see that
a lot of people get confused between
python and r
and maybe something didn't work exactly
as expected
the reason why this is useful to have on
the portal is because we want to be able
to do some basic
steps like loading data visualization of
data
and working with different types of data
to explore and understand what it means
and know that we are doing the right
thing so they are designed
to get some similar outputs that we are
expecting so that we can check that your
code works
yes you should have an account that is
the same account like on the learn
portal so if you don't have that account
you can't use the same
uh password and it doesn't log you in
then you've got a problem and so if you
can share your email address i'll make
sure that our community manager
gets back with you to to set that up
okay so do let me know if you run into
some challenges
so finally after you are done with the
basics
you can go through some of the project
examples and these project examples
illustrate some of the methods that
could be used in application to a
variety of
data types and importantly not only can
you do
projects that others have done but you
can also try to develop your own project
so at the end of today's session if we
have time i will show you how to do that
all right thank you hidaya i will ask
our community manager to look into that
so what was the assignment the last time
the last time the assignment was number
one to complete your profile on learn
omixlogic.com and complete introduction
to bioinformatics and or bytes and
molecules
number two explore server t bioinfo by
playing around with demo pipelines
and number three install r and r studio
and or python and vs code on your
computer
so how many of you have done we already
talked about one and two how many of you
have done number three so how many of
you have r
and r studio on your computer
so if you have r and r studio thank you
put number one
okay okay kisembo if you are having
trouble logging in then please put your
email address i'll ask our community
manager
to assist you with that all right
excellent so
all right so if you have um
are in our studio this is what we're
going to be doing today in
in the next session we're going to be
playing around with python
so please install python
and python 3 and install
vs code visual studio code
all right and thank you asish and
kisembo for your emails we will
check that as well is everyone here
familiar with the interface
for r in r studio
so if you're already familiar then let
me know maybe also
uh put number one or something no okay
so
for okay so let's go through
just to kind of review
so let me if you have r or r studio
please open it
so i mean open r studio
and let me know once you have it open
okay let me know once you have it open
maybe put in open
okay i'll give it just a little bit of
time for
all of you to have it in front of you so
thank you hidayah
and rebecca
anyone else
okay for those of you that are not
familiar with the interface basically
you have here
four different sections and these
sections
this one is where you write code so if
you don't have anything open here you go
to file
and you can put new file in our script
so that's what we're going to be doing
we'll do this in a little bit so here i
have
just an open file it's really a text
file with an extension.r
so here you're going to be writing the
script so the recipe
for the computer to execute here you
have your environment
in this environment you will have
different objects tables
etc that you have loaded into your
project
and so here you also will find history
connections and tutorial
but we will just deal with the
environment right now you can also
import the data set directly through
here and you can clean your environment
from all the previous things that you
might have had from a previous session
here down at the bottom you will see
files
which is just a connection for your
computer so you can see that you are in
your computer and you can set
a working folder which is important
because once you have your working
folder set up
it's much easier to call the files that
you will need
right here you have set as a working
directory or go to working directory
and so depending on where you are this
is where you want to deal with the
different files that you're going to be
using in your script
as you draw some plots and outputs
you will see them appear right here
unless you specify to save them
and here you will see the different
packages that are loaded
so you can install or load packages
by running that here in the script or
right here
in the console and if you have any
questions about
what package can do and how to write a
specific function
very useful to write it in here some of
the non-uh
visual plots like tables and things like
that could also be open
right here in the viewer okay so
hopefully this is like a very short
brief overview
that helps you understand the
environment
but as we work through the different
exercises you will definitely see
how all of this connects together in an
environment that is
easy to use so how many of you remember
what we spoke about last time
does anyone remember what was it that we
talked about last time what was the main
kind of message from our last time
[Music]
import data perfect yeah we did that at
the end
what else did we talk about
okay one of the things that we talked
about in our
last time is we talked about
what data science is and how is it going
to be applied to what we will be doing
in this program
and one of the things that we talked
about is how we go from data
to insights through specific steps
and one of the important steps is that
we can
make an action or we can understand a
data set
once that data is analyzed and
structured in such a way that we can
deal with it
and so before we get there we have to
input
and load data right so importing data
whatever data we have
and that data could be tables already
but
most likely it is not really structured
yet
and our goal is to analyze this data to
identify some relationships some
meaningful relationships
and so before we can do that we have to
deal with
unstructured data so what kinds of
unstructured data are there
for example media posts emails online
reviews
videos images speech and sound all of
these are unstructured data
we'll take a look at that in a second
there's also what's called
semi-structured data
so the semi-structured or
semi-unstructured data
means that somebody already did some
organization to it but
it's not really ready for direct
analysis
and then structured data typically would
come
in some kind of a clear table
essentially
right so to get a sense of
how to do this and durba i will get to
your question
in just a second let's do a little
exercise
so here i have an example
of unstructured data the unstructured
data here comes from a chat
right so you can see right here i have a
time point
who it's coming from and their reply
and what i would like to do to analyze
this data
is to structure this data and understand
what are the proportions of participants
that answer
a specific question that i have right so
i really want to get an
answer from all of these different
variations
i want to get a specific answer
so how do we go from that and today
we'll do a little exercise
in r to get familiar with how
all of this works so the first thing
that you will need
for that is a file
and i'm going to uh give you the link
to that file
okay so what you do is you take that
link
and you save it save it
where you know how to find it okay so
let me know
once you have downloaded the file
and right here in this box
for your files you have to find the
folder
that you saved it in
okay so you can look where did i save it
and once you get there let me know
yes
and how many of you got the file
okay so once you get that file and you
found the folder you can see i had it
kind of vary here in all kinds of
different folders
now you want to click right here
yes just save it as it is don't change
anything
so right here you have this uh
gear icon and you go to more
and you say set as working directory
right so let me know yes you save it as
it is let me know
if you got there and you have this file
so how many of you have it ready
all right thank you hidayah
okay so rebecca you go to
the home right you go to your main
folder and
you have to find the downloads in this
path
so let me set it as working directory
okay
so if you go all the way to your home
right here it should say home you should
find
downloads right here downloads
and then once your downloads just set
this as
a working directory
okay could i ask the others
it doesn't show up are you in home
i mean you must have maybe save it
instead of okay thank you
i'm reach
if you maybe save it in some other place
maybe
put it in a on the desktop or
somewhere else
uh what about durba
you guys have it ethan
dr cheney okay thank you ethan
this is yep okay ayo mede
yes you're here uh amrit hidaya
okay great
okay save it as a working directory
right here you go to this gear
and you say set as working directory and
i'm going to go to my working directory
so i have it right here
let's take a look at what this file
actually looks like
so you can see that this file is
semi-structured
first of all we separated already
the timing of the answer we have the
student
number and then we have some kind of a
score so these were some questions that
we asked
and they replied but as you can see not
everybody followed directions
so we have lowercase c large c
we have some people that put in the full
right just like we're doing now if i ask
you to put one
some people say yes right if i ask you
something else somebody else put
something else so there's no control
over this
that's how the data comes out so now i
need to
structure it right and structuring means
coming up with some kind of a taxonomy
essentially
so for example here i made a formula
and the formula basically said that if a
person says
undergraduate so here i have an answer
key if it's undergraduate degree it's
two
if it's high school it's one graduate
degree three postgraduate
four and using this formula
i can put all the numbers and save all
of the information
right here in sheet number five
so what does this data represent this
data represents
the number of students that i have and
what is their level of education
now let's try to
load this data and try to find what we
want to understand
about these students so what do we do
first
what kind of a data is this
what format is this who remembers what
format
and how do you actually you open this
format
and by the way we don't have to just
chat you're free to unmute yourself
okay it is organized yes but what format
is it what format of file
is it
exactly excellent so to open that we
need a library
we don't just use the base functionality
of r
we need a library and this library
is called open
x lsx
okay so if you write open
or library open xlxx
to run this library you can go right
here
and run it okay so that will execute
this code and sometimes
you will see that you don't have this
library
okay so what to do if you don't have a
library
you go to tools and right here you can
install a package
and you find it in the list of packages
and you already have a path to where all
your data is stored all of your packages
and you just click install
and so down here you can see everything
that you tell the computer to do it does
and so here when it's running you
probably saw there's a little stop sign
and that means it executed this and you
can see that it
installed it okay so now if you run it
again
you see that it loaded the library and
there are no errors does everyone have
the library
ready
so maybe okay excellent
thank you rebecca are you getting a
are you getting an heir
did you get some kind of an error i
don't even know where i'm looking
what am i looking for so i pasted
library
open excel access whatever right so now
what do i do
you run it like this you click on the
right there run where
right oh okay it's like tiny my screen
is tiny okay
i run it what is it
what does it say down here nothing
so it just says like this no it doesn't
say that
are you sure that you're on console
yes yes i'm on that tab
if i have to install something what does
that mean okay so what you can do is you
can copy this
just the name of the library go to tools
install packages
and then right here it has packages you
install
install packages
and uh hidayah do you want to install
from sources the package which needs
compilation
i guess yes
okay so once you find it in the packages
you just click on install
and by the way um
i don't know why you would not have um
your console
but let me know if that works for you
rebecca
okay
so hidayah did you get it installed
and how do you check that it's installed
you just run it
no what happened when you
got that message did you say yes
okay for durba it worked so hidayah
maybe you can just unmute yourself and
quickly explain what happened
so nothing should happen right we didn't
do anything we just loaded a library
okay so nothing really should work but
we'll find out in a second
if it's working on that so the second
thing that we want to do is we want to
create an
object what is an object anything can be
an
object i can make an object whatever
name i want to give it
i can so i will call this object
education
level now in r your capital letters are
important
so if you make this education level with
capitals
then you have to refer to it by capitals
as well
in r we use this to
make to mean equal but really you can
also use the equal sign
a lot of times people use this just
because it's easier to separate
when a variable is equal to something as
opposed to loading something into an
object
so right now we created an object and we
want to load into this object
the answers that we have this
read answers to question so the function
so why is it called a library because it
contains a library like a dictionary
of different terms or functions and the
function that we will use
is read.xlsx
so all it does is it reads this type of
a file
and then we have to put in here the name
so answers
to questions that excel is
x
and we want to specify which sheet so
which sheet that we actually
use the level of education
right education level is sheet number
one two
three four five so sheet number five so
right here
you put in sheet equals to five
now to try that it works always when you
wanna try something that works you can
select it
and you can click on run
so what happened now in our working
environment
we have here the education level
is an object and you can see if you
hover over it that it says
data frame
okay so how many of you have the data
frame working i can
paste this for you all right
thank you thank you ethan
all right madeline
rebecca did it work for you
okay so again the working directory once
you find the directory
you just click right here
and you say set as working director but
you have to find the directory here
first you have to see the file
okay i see that maybe
okay then find the desktop so go to your
desktop
and then set it as working directory
okay so
for those of you that are still
struggling with some of these technical
things
we will have a recording of this maybe
you can try that again
or we have some exercises for you to try
you can try and do this
on the portal that way you can get
started
all right what do we want to do next the
next thing
is that we want to load a particular
type or a particular column from here
right so what do we actually need
we need this column score
how do we load a score we can say
for example make a table
or make another object or let's call
this score
and load in here education
level and we use the dollar sign
and you see when i put the dollar sign
it already tells me what are the
different
columns that i have so time
name and score
okay so yes in the beginning when you
install r
it does automatically set the directory
for your working directory but you can
always find it right here on top and
change it
right so here we want to take the score
so now if we run this
you can see that now we got the numbers
we had a total
26 students and now we have the answers
for those students right here
okay did everyone get the score
all right now
okay yep
okay
all right so we have one two three four
anyone else
okay is that everyone else uh still
stuck or do we have
um so rebecca did it start okay rebecca
works for you great madeline
madeline did uh it worked for you
okay kisembo
uh maybe some of you already know this
so uh dr cheney does it work for you
all right so
not yet okay so uh let me know where
exactly you're
um okay waiting to complete install
okay all right so bye next time
hopefully this is already working for
you guys
i'll show you in a second how we can
perform all the same
in the omixlogic portal so you don't
have to
figure out all of the installations so
now let's create a plot
okay we saw how here we have our
environment
let's first actually just print it so
you can say print
and for example
the sum of all of our scores
score one now often times
when you get some kind of a
error it is because you did something
wrong in
writing maybe if i put here
lower capital s and i run it you can see
air in prince some score object score
not found
right i don't have an object i can see
here what kind of objects i have it's
not there it doesn't know how to do it
but if i do this correctly okay
and i print it and you see that the
total is 79. now it's meaningless
so this is not really useful so i can
just delete this
but let's try to create a plot okay
what kind of a plot would be useful
to visually see this data what do you
think
kind of a plot do you think would be
useful here
what would be a useful way to look at
this data
what do you guys think
bar plot okay so what would you like at
the tio
for this bar plot to show what would be
a meaningful way to show this data
should i just have
okay kissembo is saying histogram so i
could look at the distribution of these
numbers i don't know how useful that is
maybe
it will give me some sense which numbers
i have more or less but it doesn't seem
like i have
continuous data this is really
categorical data i only have from one to
four
and if i want to look at this data in a
meaningful way what i would do
is i would actually
yes the number of students that had each
score right so i would want to look at
how many are twos how many are ones how
many are fours etcetera right
so instead of just a bar plot i'm
actually looking
to summarize the data in some meaningful
way
and so to do that first of all we need
to
put our uh put this information into
a table okay so for example we can say
table one
and then put here table and
we can put education
level score
so if i do this
you can see that it is a table so this
object is called a table so it's very
similar thing to what we did here but
it's really a table and once i have that
table
i can just say table one and
if i run it what will happen you can see
that
now it is organized into how many i have
of which
so i have two of ones six of twos
seven of threes and eleven of fours
okay so it's kind of exactly what we
need right
okay did everybody get this table one
if you want to try this and you don't
exactly want to look at my screen
here's the latest okay did everybody get
this
and thank you i'm rich ethan
and zion
thank you are you meeting anyone else
madeline lesice
all right who else do we have
durba okay and if you're still waiting
on this to install
then unfortunately we'll have to wait
until next time now let's try to create
a prop table so what we can do is we can
first of all say prop
so what did this give us it not only
counted how many do we have but it
calculated the average
the percentages for
each category right so the categories
are one two three four
this one is eight percent almost 23
27 42 right so it's useful
for us to know how to do this and now
let's create
a bar plot so if we do a bar plot
of table one
and let's run it
so we get a chart or we have a plot
right right here we have this plot
tab and it shows us in a visual format
what the data looks like so just by
looking at this
what number has the most number four
what number has the least number one
right
did everybody get this
all right perfect air
okay rebecca what does the air say
error in table education score
object education not found
okay do you have education level
is it exactly like this because it's
important to make sure that all of your
spelling here is correct
i don't know i thought i copied and
pasted all of your stuff
yeah but it could be that i just gave
you a portion of what i had i didn't
give you the whole thing
but if you want the whole thing i can
give you the whole thing so
copy and paste this because right here
you have all of your objects so if one
of them is named differently
it's not going to work okay
let me know that works
do i have to delete everything that's in
the
box before i copy and paste what you
just gave me yeah this box should just
be what i gave you
okay sorry
all right so the combination of this
don't have an error it's still in there
what is the area yeah
what is there in table education score
education level score this is not
finding this
what do you have right here do you have
education level like this far as i can
tell it looks
like that yeah and do you have this
score right here does it
show score yep and then i have values
score numbers one through 126 two two
one four blah blah blah
and then table won't table won't do it
okay
i don't know why can you copy exactly
what is the error right here you can
just copy and paste what it says
sure
object education is not found
okay and so it's because it should say
education level not just education but
education level
see somehow it does it does
well but it tells you that object
education not found because your object
is called
education level so you have to
are you running it in pieces or
something
i don't know what you mean by running it
in pieces but i don't think so i copied
and pasted what you put in the chat
and i put it in as best i can tell it
looks like what's in your window and now
that's what it's telling me am i
supposed to install something to do the
table
maybe i need to install something no you
don't need to install anything
okay i have no idea well it just tells
you right there that
it it shows us what's in your script
right and if you just read it
it says that your line says table one is
table and then in parentheses education
dollar sign score and so you don't have
an object called
education that's what it's complaining
about so why don't you just go in there
or you can also copy and paste what you
have in here or
maybe you can share your screen if you
want to and we can see what the air is
can i share my screen i mean i think you
should be able to yeah
well it says i can't share because
you're sharing
hey i'll stop sharing okay
go let's pick the right screen there we
go
i mean is it sharing no share click
share
okay so now can you run it
click this run right yeah but just
when you click that that's just the
selections you gotta select everything
and then run it there's the missing
piece
okay how about now okay i'm so sorry all
right
all right so now we got it working
now let's just summarize this by adding
a little bit more information to this
plot
so it actually makes sense so the first
thing that we want to do
is we want to give it some color i like
colors
so we can say call equals call stands
for color
rainbow and the length
so the number of colors that we need
is going to be answers
uh sorry we actually need to say
how many well let's just do four
because we know how many we have so
we'll just put
four
and then we'll give it a title so when
you say main will be the title
so what is the title of this plot the
title of this plot
is summary of maybe student
answers
okay so now we can
also add what these answers
are okay but to do that
i'm sorry to make it a little bit
confusing
let's add the answers so what are the
answers
the answers what are these numbers
one two three four are right here one
two three four have
the answers right here so how do we get
that
what we need to do is we need to load
not sheet five but cheat four
so let's create another variable
and we will again do read excel as
x again let's write it out
answers to
questions we can just copy this
but sheet equals four
okay for those of you that want to try
this later at home
i will share this in the chat so just
make sure you
add it in the right place and let's
run it
all right so now i have answers one and
it has four objects with two variables
why two variables i have answer and
number
right and then once i have this
information
i can actually use this information to
replace these one two three four
okay so the way i would do that is i
would add
here
names so these would be the names of my
things and i will say answers
one
and the column would be answer
right so let's try that
so this is what i have now let's put it
right here
all right run it and let me know if you
got the same
all right great madeline
and great well it looks much better
right
okay just give you a couple more minutes
if uh you're having an
air do let me know you then thank you
ah to die
rebecca
okay ayo miday
yep thank you durba is it still
okay you probably what about um
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
dua hidayah kisembo
let me know okay so if you want to do
this later at home
what can you do with this what you can
do is you can just save the whole script
make sure that you save it in a file
now try to play around with this maybe
give it some
different kind of data and to talk about
different kinds of data which is what we
will discuss today
and i will try to do this fairly brief
we want to talk about this is just an
example an example how we went
from fairly complicated semi-structured
data
that looked like this in the beginning
to something that we were able to
summarize
and then visually present to get an
answer the question was
how many or what is the biggest category
of people that we have and the answer is
postgraduate students
okay so now let's talk about what other
types of data are we going to be dealing
with because really
this is small data right this data is
small
this data is simple it's intuitive we
know how to look at this data and make
sense of this data what we don't know
is what is in the big data right and so
what kinds of omics data
have we talked about previously can
anyone remember
what are some examples of data types
that we talked about before
does anyone remember yeah what kinds of
data did we talk about last time
onyx data that's key but what kinds of
omnics data do you know
genomics okay good example what else
transcriptomics metabolomics
one more
metadrone okay excellent so here we have
some overview of different types of data
phenomics we can talk about phenotypes
if it's high throughput that it probably
is automatically generated so this could
be
for example cell morphology genomics
really represents
genomic variants so this could mean
that it's categorical data data that is
a t c and g but it is across the whole
genome or the whole egg zone so that's
why it's called omics a collection of
that kind of data
epigenomics epigenomic data could be
chip seek data whole genome by sulfite
sequencing data
all kinds of data it looks like this it
looks like peaks in specific areas
that are from a pull down of a protein
that binds to a particular location so
you know
how to look at structure of chromatin
or maybe dna methylation or maybe even
mirna regulation with microrna and then
transcriptomics so transcriptomics
represents the expression of genes and
isoforms
and we can capture the variability at
the level
quantifying the levels of expression or
looking at differences
in specific types of arrangements of
exons and introns which is called
alternative splicing
now with all of this data the key step
is processing so what we did today in
the little exercises we actually
converted data through multiple steps
from one way that it looks to another
way that it looks right and that is the
processing we didn't do anything with
the data right before we summarized it
we were just
transforming the way it looks and so in
the case of
omnics data that's a very important step
and you have to know how to do it and in
our next session we're going to learn
how to do that to actually process this
data why does it need
processing raw data looks like this here
you can see
reads these are the individual portions
of data that are
150 to 350 nucleotides long
each one of these reads contains
sequences
but together those sequences need to be
analyzed because they map
on some location of the genome and now
we deal with this huge data that could
be
gigabytes or even terabytes in size and
what do we want to get out of this data
again we want to get some kind of
answers
so how do we go about those answers
let's first of all talk about
genomic data genomic data represents
sequences of tcgna and the answer we're
looking for are specific
mutations oftentimes so here you see
a vcf file does anyone know what a vcf
file
stands for
what is a vcf file what does vc and f
stand for
okay vcf stands for variant call
format so instead of looking at all of
the positions
we want to only call the specific
positions so what you can see right here
and this position right here is 7
million
or sorry 76 million six
no seven million six hundred and seventy
four thousand two hundred and twenty
so that position contains a snip
it contains a mutation and so instead of
looking at
all of the data i just look at data this
is chromosome
for some reason this says chromosome 17.
yeah so this is okay so this is
chromosome 17
and you can see that right here in this
position we find
these two mutations so this is the
outcome of processing just selecting
this kind of data
now a question is if we have
this kind of categorical data remember
it's only
four possibilities tcgna what would be
a way to convert this data to numeric
data because really
what we can analyze with a lot of the
methods
that require statistics and machine
learning
they would be ha they would have to be
continuous
so the answer to that is that we can
actually assign
each letter a score and the score
is typically a result of analysis
considering all of the input data that
you have
so how many of the reads
depending on where it is how many and
which
which conversion it is you can actually
calculate a semantic score what do you
get
as a result as a result for each
position
you have a semantic score so a number
and based on this number you can now
filter
using some kind of a threshold and get a
result
and then the rest of that information is
interpretation
so how does a particular mutation a
change
can actually affect some kind of a
disease a phenotype
in this case you are looking at sickle
cell and
a mutation that happens in patients with
sickle cell disease
that actually causes this disease so
from raw data going through the steps of
processing
then selecting some kind of information
that we need
and then going to interpretation another
type
of data that we will be looking at is
okay so yeah that's the mutation that's
hemoglobin right here
so this information descri is described
in the genomics course that you will
find
on learn on xlogic.com and it is really
divided up into several different
sections
introduction to genomics genomics one
that talks about somatic
mutations and then genomics two where
you look at
other types of ways that you can analyze
such data
an important consideration here as you
can see is that
to make this data intuitive we have to
have a way
to interpret this information so how do
we go from finding mutations
to then knowing what is their effect on
the biological interaction
we use the central dogma of molecular
biology
to connect the two to say that we know
that nucleotides form tricodons
those form amino acids a change in a
nucleotide could result
in a change in the protein structure
that's why we want to associate
how the protein structure changes
because of the
mutation that we found in the data so in
the same way
we now can turn to alternative splicing
and expression of genes or
transcriptomic data analysis so when we
talk about transcriptomic data
we are really looking at how we can
measure
levels of gene expression or alternative
splicing
of specific transcripts or isoforms
so that we can also understand what is
the outcome
and associate that with a particular
phenotype or
again a condition or a change so this
requires
again multiple steps in the processing
pipeline
this is called a pipeline what does a
pipeline essentially do
a pipeline loads the data just like we
did in our script we loaded the data
first
then we pass it on to a library a
function
in the library and that function
performs maybe some very complex
calculations on all of our data and
provides some
output once it does that it passes this
output on to the next job and so from
job to job
they are organized here in a logical way
so you go from pre-processing or
cleaning your raw data
then to mapping it onto the genome then
constructing isoforms and saving them
into a gtf
file then mapping the
amount of transcripts that fall in a
certain segment
and quantifying that to provide us
with a structured output what is that
structured output looks like
again like a table this table now has
different elements
and those elements are samples all of
our columns have
sample names and genes and so
at the intersection of gene and sample
we again
have an expression level does anyone
have any questions about this
okay so we're talking about how do we go
from raw sequencing data
or raw unstructured data to structure
data
that has continuous numbers so these
numbers are
continuous all of the information about
transcriptomic data analysis is found in
the transcriptomics course so
in between now and the next few sessions
you're welcome to take a look at some of
those
and see what's in there now finally the
third data type that i want to introduce
today
is what's called metagenomic data
so how many of you know what does the
metagenomic data represent
additional mentioned metagenomics so
what kind
of information can we find in the
metagenomic data
okay any suggestions what do you think
metagenomics means
okay metadata is about is data about
data that's good either
okay microorganisms okay thank you so
what is different between metagenomic
data
and let's say genomic transcriptomic
metabolomic
and others is that metagenomic data
describes a collection of organisms and
not just a single one
and instead of analyzing an individual
organism we're really looking at a
community
and that community instead of giving us
the differences between an individual
and another individual
really shows us something like a
proportion and that proportion
together with what we know about
relationships between microorganisms
at the evolutionary level provides us
with a sense
of community structure and that
community structure is defined by
how we think how distant
and proportionate they are to each other
because the idea is that
a single sample of microorganisms
represents a community that functions
together in a very defined way in a
stable way
and so when we sample that environmental
sample we are looking at
a composition of what's called the
microbiome
to achieve that goal we have to
disregard
the small differences between what we
have in our data and focus on
groups and these groups we call
operational taxonomic units or otus
operational how many of you know what a
taxonomy is
okay so rebecca what is the taxonomy
what what a taxonomic unit is or i mean
it's just a way to divide the bacteria
in my mind maybe that's not what you
meant no no that's exactly what i mean
so it's a way to
look at our data and organize them into
groups right
so genera or species or something like
that
exactly yes so the taxonomy is
how do we fit this individual that we
might not know
which genome it's coming from into some
kind of a group
that we can define by the level of
taxonomy
species etc so to do that
we again take raw reads those raw reads
contain
a lot of variability and one of the
challenges is to
distinguish between variability that is
technical
or comes from errors and find accurate
data
and there's a pipeline or a whole
section of different types of methods
called data2 that you can see
almost exclusively focuses on going from
raw data to assigning that taxonomy
to a group of units and those units
are collections of reeds and then after
we have them
we can now analyze them for the
relationship or the
phylogeny how they are related to each
other
and then we can create all kinds of
visualizations using this
filo seek package so
what do we want to get out of this
information typically out of this
information
we want to analyze variability
or we want to organize our data visually
into these groups that make biological
sense
so we're really combining information
that comes from data analysis
with our understanding of biology that
could be the reason for what we observe
in the data and so these are some of the
plots that we're going to be building
also in this program and all of the
information about this is going to be
available
in the metagenomics coursework but it's
important to remember that there's a lot
of overlap
as you can see we also want to get a
table
the table now has instead of genes like
we had in transcriptomic data
operational taxonomic units we have
samples
and abundance so this abundance
is a proportionate abundance to what we
have
overall also
we need to combine this with annotation
and the annotation
provides us with that taxonomic
organization so for each one of these
otus
in one table i have how many or the
proportion that i have in the whole
sample
and then i can annotate them based on
what is known
from a database okay
any questions about this
all right so no questions about this the
process
overall for each one of these data sets
is we first have to process the data
then we have to explore the data for
variability that we can understand
and then we need to define what is the
hypothesis so in many cases
what we will do today or not today but
in this whole program
is we're not going to go create generate
a hypothesis and generate data
we're going to be taking other people's
data and using that data
to ask questions about the data so first
of all we're going to generate a
hypothesis
and then we're going to find the answer
to that hypothesis
or interpretation that we can make sense
of in a biological way so
this whole process of data analysis will
be
based on data that we analyze and mine
first
and then ask the questions about it
later now
here's an example of one of the data
sets that we will be looking at
the example comes from a publication
called modeling precision treatment of
breast cancer
it is a publication that takes a look at
70 breast cancer cell lines or sorry 84
breast cancer cell lines
out of which some of them have been
tested
with drugs so we know how they respond
to different types of treatments
and they have different types of data
different types of almonds data so it's
a multi-omic data set
and what we would like to know is how
based on the data that we have
do they can we use this to predict
the best treatment for a patient right
so if you imagine
a patient that comes and
we have all of this data about them how
can
we predict what would be their response
for uh what we have um
for their response ultimately when
they're treated with
the drugs and so you can see here in the
abstract and the results that are
reported in this paper
how they used molecular profiling which
is
the data that we talked about today to
identify specific features like genes
to predict therapeutic responses and
actually find optimal predictors which
might be a combination of multiple and
not just one
that will predict that response to
treatment
now as you read through the results you
will start seeing
what methods that they actually use to
do that and you will find words like
support vector machines random forest
and these are machine learning
algorithms that we will learn how to use
to be able to do same types of
predictions that we we see they
did in this paper so ultimately
why are we doing why did we select
these specific projects and what are we
going to be trying to imitate
during this program that is dedicated to
biomedical data
a lot what happens in the clinic
is dependent on precise data
that has been analyzed from thousands of
patients
and so a good example of that is
prediction
of survival so in many cases
we know that patients groups of patients
actually respond differently
to treatment more better or worse
and therefore over time if we collect
data about patients over time we can
know that some
are going to be more at high risk
or have a lower risk which is associated
with the outcome
how many years do they have to live
after they were treated
and so here you can see two panels
that are based on gene expression data
and that can
separate all of the patients at an early
stage right here at year two or three
very effectively to know their outcome
over time another way that this data
could be used
is to select the appropriate method of
treatment from traditional treatments
that are available for example here if
we're looking at
surgical radiotherapy or chemotherapy
all of these therapies come with an
additional risk
that could lead the patient to develop a
different type of cancer for example
and so knowing which type of treatment
to select
oftentimes is related to risk
stratification and risk stratification
in this case
is going to be defined again using
molecular
data now the other example is targeted
therapy
and targeted therapy means that we can
take information from the molecular data
at what's going on inside the cell and
use that information
to understand what type of proteins for
example could be targeted
so how can we make a treatment that is
going to treat specifically that patient
and not anybody else and so here you can
see
that the key word here is biomarker
a lot of time the biomarker could also
be the mechanism of
action and so a good example for
mechanism of action
is when we have herceptin herceptin is a
drug that binds to the her2 protein
to stop the growth factor receptor
from signaling a signal to the nucleus
to produce
different types of genes involved in
growth and uncontrolled replication
so what we will do in the program is we
will
replicate what we did today but instead
of using
survey data data that we understand we
will take omics data
and from that onyx data we will go to
use
r and python today we did a little bit
of r in our next session we will do a
little bit of python
to load the data visualize the data
and see what does this data actually
mean
so um i think at this point that's all
we have for today
i do want to introduce you to some of
the data sets
that we will be using so um
if you can go with me to the
server portal sorry
okay and i will show you where you can
find
some of the data sets that we are going
to be relying on
in this program so please let me know
once you're here
okay maybe put something in chat once
you've reached the website and you're
logged in
all right thank you madeline dr cheney
all right so when you are here you will
find that different types of data
ngs data for example transcriptomic
genomics
etc you can find next
to a particular section a drop down
right so here you have different types
of drop downs
the drop downs are for demo pipelines
the demo pipelines contain data sets
that
are already analyzed okay so here you
can see
different project examples
these project examples and you will do a
lot more of this in the next session
but these project examples come with an
input all of the steps to process and
the output
so here you click on start
you can then go through the steps to
pre-process the data
so again these are steps in the pipeline
then map this on the genome
construct isoforms
merge those isoforms into the genome
transfer format or gtf
quantify the levels of expression and
you can see what that
outcome would be is a table
and then when you click on end
right here in the downloads you will
find the information that you will need
to process the data and analyze it
okay so how many of you got this result
okay just to show you what are the steps
to do
here are the steps so let me know once
you've got this result
does anyone need me to repeat this
okay yeah i i think uh kind of stuck on
your previous screen
okay so let's go to areas of analysis
and right here under transcriptomics you
open this drop-down arrow
open the rna-seq cell line project the
first one
asking for my credential let's see it
should be the same though
the other credential we use for onyx
all right then you start which
tells you a little bit of what the
pipeline could look like
and there are multiple ones that you can
do here
and that's how you can play around with
this and get to understand the logical
steps
for example now i'll make a different
pipeline so from here i can go to bow
tie to t
and just create a table of expression in
a faster way
click on end and get a result
right and then when you get the result
let me know
all right excellent not only got the
result so if you got the result
let us look right here cell lines
do you need the steps hey dianna here
are the steps
so start trim-o-matic pcr clean
bow tie 2t r7 expression table
and
once you are done download this file
cell lines clean type txt
all right and now let's try
just like we loaded the survey data
we're going to
load in this information from this
pipeline
okay so i need to know how many people
got it
madeline ethan hidaya were you able to
get this
no rebecca where where are you are you
do you have the pipeline
okay so i don't know what happened so
i went back to the top page so i'm under
transcriptomics
and i click on what cell rna-seq what am
i looking at
that one right i click on that right
[Music]
then i get to this and i'm supposed to
click on what
start start
the window pops up okay okay
trimmermatic
oh i just i just keep clicking okay okay
pc or clean vote
to t
rsv expression table
and
and you open this folder and download
this file
yes okay thanks yeah so once you have it
again what do we need to do right here
we loaded some
answers to questions let's create a new
file
our script okay
and now again we have to navigate to
that folder
right so since we most of us saved it in
the downloads we have to find
the downloads folder
and then here under more say
set as working directory
and now we need to open uh
sorry let's create a cell types
object and you can just
you know go back here and kind of see
what you did before
now this is already a txt right
so what we need to do is we need to say
open
open could be
different type of open so if you
write this you can see here different
options
you can see all of these are options it
will tell you kind of what
you are doing or you can
do load
so you can play around with this
and the file
remember you put the um
quotation marks
okay so if we do this
okay if you try to do this remember
that this will not work
because of how we define
what it is that we are opening
now how do you and this will be your
assignment for the next time
so i'm not going to give you all the
answers in this case because you already
know where to find the answers how do
you
get this into your our
studio let's go to learn and we'll find
a course where you can practice
some of these things so if you go here
and you do
data science introduction to data
science and
r
okay go to how to load data and check
for variable data
okay and then here you will have some
examples and we're not going to
go through them including trying them
yourself to actually get this data in
and do the same thing that we did before
right so your output should be
just like we did here but instead of
answers to questions we want to know
how different types so you will
see here there are different columns you
can see cell line
name you can see transcriptional subtype
cell line cell type etc so you will have
to figure out how from this data
do i build a bar plot
okay so similar to what we had here
for four different types of
cell lines okay and these are
normal-like basal luminal
and cloud and low okay so your
assignment
is to find which type
has the most which type has the least
okay where do you find the answers on
how to actually do this
in this course
and then when you want to
visualize you go through here and you
follow this tutorial
on how to visualize this data
okay does anyone have any questions
okay so there are no questions um
kisembo um and
i think someone else posted here i have
your emails
noted down that you did not have access
so i will make sure that you have access
did everyone join the slack channel
everyone here are you a part of the
slack channel for this program
okay okay so if you are not a part
then you need to go to the program page
again look here for the lbrn
data science program
and once you're in here you scroll all
the way down here to the bottom and you
will see
the slack channel so if you click on
ask a question
it will redirect you to the channel okay
which means that this will uh if you
have slack installed of course
then you should be right here ldran onyx
logic data science program
so please send me a message here
if you're in here then just maybe reply
to me
or say hello or something and then
if you need to install slack or
something like that
let me know in the chat once you're in
here
so i see that amrit is here let's find
and read
okay so there's them marines there's
madeline
okay all right ethan is installing slack
great
all right perfect so here if you
go through the tutorials and you have
any questions or you're struggling with
something
please let me know my name is elia right
here
so you can mention me and i'll be happy
to help you with
whatever you're struggling with and
another person that's going to be
guiding the sessions his name is clinton
so you can mention clinton here right
here clinton
he will be teaching the next session
okay so dp um if you gave me already
your email address it should be in here
i will reach out to you with the details
shortly after the session
all right so hopefully all of you um are
here or soon will be
okay christina again
uh christina the way to find
the slack channel is to go into the
program page
so this is the program page
and once you're here you go to the very
bottom and it says
ask a question you click on here
and then it will open a redirect
to this channel all right hello three
okay and there's three here in
in the session
okay all right great
got it got it dp
okay
all right so let's see we have here
uh amrit sri or dp
joseph
let's see if everybody else can join us
just to make sure okay well it's 4 30.
so i think we're out of time but i'm
looking forward to interacting with you
here
we'll have another session on monday so
before monday if you could try
and work on this assignment so again
in here in our studio try to load this
data
and make a summary plot of the types of
cell lines
found in this data set if you want to
read a little bit more
about this publication of where the data
came from
this is the publication just to
understand what were they trying to do
and what are the different omics data
types that they used
i think they're very fascinating even
though it's somewhat old it's
from 2013 but a very nice study that
they did there
thank you everyone have a great weekend
i will try to
address all of your questions as okay
hello becky
so i will try to address all of your
questions if you struggle with something
then let me know here in slack
have a great weekend everyone
thank you